vsauce kevin here with a serial killer
who may very well have murdered hundreds
her systematic killing spree went
undetected for years because suspicion
just wasn't enough
what finally brought her to justice
was mad don't leave me here they're
gonna kill me they kill people here
you know i did it i did it you wanted to
know i killed those guys
in the united states the most dangerous
place you can go
is the hospital
yes doctors and nurses save lives
literally every single day but medical
error is a significant cause of death no
matter how hard we try tragedies happen
and by definition everyone in a hospital
is already sick with something but
murder isn't an accident and a nurse in
massachusetts was straight up killing
patients to impress a guy
kristen gilbert was a nurse at the
veterans administration medical center
in northampton massachusetts she was
popular with co-workers she'd go out
clubbing with them in boston to blow off
steam and even through baby showers she
also seemed to be really good at her job
it felt like she was always around to
save the day in an emergency
she appeared to be the perfect nurse
but gilbert was around so often when
patients died that other nurses jokingly
referred to her as
the angel of death
it seemed like the northampton hospital
had a lot of unexpected deaths but a va
investigation found that the hospital's
rate of deaths was in line with similar
va hospitals
so
case closed right wrong
doctors and nurses weren't convinced but
there were no witnesses who saw gilbert
actually do anything suspicious to
patients
there wasn't any evidence but there was
data
here's a question how often did patients
die when gilbert was on the floor
compared to when she wasn't
was there a correlation between her
presence and patient deaths and if so
was it just an unlucky coincidence or
was she killing people
the first analysis can be expressed
visually this graph shows patient deaths
in the hospital ward between 1988 and
1997 broken down into three shifts day
evening and overnight
the 4 pm to midnight evening shift
stands out as having the most deaths and
kristin gilbert worked the evening shift
but that doesn't hold for every year
1988 and 89 don't match up with the six
years that follow it there weren't that
many deaths and they were pretty evenly
distributed throughout the day kristin
gilbert didn't start working on the ward
until 1990. okay okay what about the
really high number of deaths during
overnight shifts in 1990
that's an outlier in this whole data set
gilbert worked evenings but when she
started in 1990
she worked
the overnight shift
huh
yeah
but this graph is still not proof
variation in human outcomes is
tremendous whether it's education or
physical fitness or death
it's totally possible that kristen
gilbert was present during a statistical
blip
it's possible there's some nurse out
there working on a floor where patients
never seem to die like some kind of
angel of life just ask brandon mayfield
whether coincidences happen or the fbi
dr steven gelbach who is now dean
emeritus of umass amherst school of
public health ran the numbers he looked
at
1641 nursing shifts over the period of
18 months leading up to staff taking
their concerns to hospital management
there were 74 deaths during those shifts
which is a death on 4.51
of all shifts
or .045 deaths per shift kristin gilbert
worked 257 shifts during that 18-month
period with .045 deaths per shift we'd
expect her to be present for about 11 or
12 deaths
about 1 every 6 weeks on average
15 or 16 deaths when you expect 11 or 12
could be an unlucky statistical anomaly
she was there for 40
40.
a patient died on over 15
of gilbert's shifts
what are the chances of that
we'll find out in a second this video is
sponsored by babel the number one
language learning app in the world with
over 10 million subscriptions choose
from over a dozen different languages
and babel teaches you real world
practical conversations whether you're
learning for travel business or
relationships in quick 10-minute
interactive lessons it teaches you more
than just vocab words you'll learn about
that language's culture like slang
holidays food and drink and more here
check this out
[Music]
so whether you want to connect with
someone advance your career or just
expand your language horizons babel is
the award-winning technology that has
you covered they even have a 20-day
money-back guarantee so click the link
below to get 65 off your subscription
and thanks to babel for supporting
vsauce2 okay so what are the chances
literally 1 in 100 million and maybe
even less in the handwriting analysis i
did of sylvia howland's will hedy
green's forgery matched on way too many
points to chalk it up to a crazy
coincidence one in sextillions gelbach
calculated p-values to estimate the
chance of gilbert's nursing death rate
at less than 1 in 100 million but we
know from the sally clark trial that a
probability like 1 in 73 million isn't
necessarily what it feels like it is
correlation isn't causation maybe her
patients were just sicker than normal
this time that uncertainty
was okay it was enough for the grand
jury to proceed a grand jury doesn't
have to determine guilt or innocence the
way a trial does they just decide
whether the evidence is compelling
enough to proceed with criminal charges
they did
again there wasn't proof
but the math gave enough context to the
suspicions of the veterans
administration hospital management and
gilbert's co-workers to proceed with
charges but
how was she killing these people
and
why
prosecutors allege that gilbert had
injected patients with epinephrine which
you probably know as adrenaline which
sped up their hearts and caused cardiac
failure adrenaline is untraceable but
the hospital found that it had a lot of
epinephrine go missing during gilbert's
employment and
some of the patients like henry huden
who was relatively young and a paranoid
schizophrenia patient weren't likely to
have three heart attacks in one night
without something artificially causing
it but
why would a professional mother of two
in suburbia become a deranged super
villain
well
she seemed to have delusions of grandeur
in which she herself put patients in
critical condition and then heroically
tried to resuscitate them she had a
history of manipulative behavior mental
illness and abuse of patients
as a home care aide in the 1980s she
scalded a mentally disabled child with
hot bath water on purpose
kristin gilbert may have been unhinged
but she was also
in love
obsessively
in love
every time a patient coded hospital
policy mandated that a police officer
engage in cpr in late 1995 and early 96
the same police officer responded to
every single cardiac arrest that gilbert
reported james perrault
kristen's boyfriend
the man she left her husband and two
children for
witnesses noticed her touching peralta
affectionately during resuscitation
efforts and wiping his sweaty brow court
papers show that one witness will
testify that he observed gilbert playing
footsie with perrault
during the middle of a code
gross perrault ended the relationship
and gilbert was angry on a phone call
from a psychiatric facility she
confessed to him by saying you know i
did it
i did it
you wanted to know i killed those guys
perrault immediately went to the
authorities so she
called in a bomb threat to the va
hospital where they worked
decades of troubling behavior culminated
in a systemic killing spree that allowed
gilbert to be the focal point of crisis
after crisis
staff testified about her access to the
adrenaline that induced cardiac events
and doctors testified that the
unexpected excess deaths were often
relatively healthy middle-aged men the
same pattern
just kept happening
kristin gilbert was convicted of four
murders and two attempted murders and
the bomb threat to a federal facility
it's possible and probable that she was
involved in many
many more patient deaths that weren't
the accidents they seemed to be but
prosecutors couldn't prove it she could
have faced the death penalty but a
compassionate judge and jury sentenced
her to a life in prison without the
possibility of parole plus 20 years
the mathematical analysis that was so
critical to gilbert's downfall wasn't
even used in the trial the trial judge
ruled that the statistical evidence was
prejudicial as it likely wouldn't be
understood by the jury as not being
ironclad numerical proof of her guilt
i've shown that math can be an
incredible asset in court or that it can
turn innocent people into criminals
we're getting used to scientific and
mathematical evidence like dna and
forensics determining guilt or innocence
but
the reality is
math and science don't have to do all
the work
dozens and maybe hundreds of veterans
are alive in massachusetts
because of a bar graph
math and science don't always have to
put out the fire
sometimes
all they should do
all they
need to do
is
sound the alarm
and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you